garrier for blue god but at the same
time I'm not sure wins yeah well yeah I
guess it all depends on how quickly he
can possibly establish aggression right
because states rights could matter in
that because I think God is just gonna
attack if we saw if we saw what he did
force is skill right
the main difference was no I'm good I'm
gonna attack really at the start I'm
just gonna rush in your face I don't
know what have the whole time sometimes
you want to make sure you get your your
stance ready right you want to make sure
where you have a created weapon but here
we go this is gonna be winners finals on
the first Soul Calibur world tour event
here at Evo Japan 2020 blue God versus
you Toto I believe this one will be a
best-of-five set first of three that's
right first of three coming out and it's
gonna be on one of the most volatile
stages in the goal you could just die
for no reason a nice break that was a
fourth delasco broken yeah but awareness
looks not like one of his drawers were
gonna wring him out right so I think he
was probably you know thinking like the
I know that you know six B he's it's
only level one way did amazing time I
got to do with the mix-up here nice step
yeah I mean you know I Baltimore has the
horizontal he can do there but I can't
we got to talk already snoo he'll take
that into that to a so you can be at
Almighty God I think we got there's all
about that
let's go for the mid keep it nice and
simple
oh wow okay so you get the call right
there he's gonna be back into almighty
mode as well he pops to go back to their
point blank game is extremely Shahs look
I just did not win you total to have any
pressure there
6p to interrupt right there Baldo has
has a hard time present buttons at that
rate over the 50/50 right now a lot of
course quickly that card as well agreed
but block oh that's gonna be guaranteed
yeah the only option he had there was
two radii and I mean again it's a 50/50
it's hindsight there's no way he could
know for sure I'm really impressed at
how well blue cod is opening up new
Toto's defense man you're right he's
working that guard whoa okay GI facing
down right now back turn K that's one of
the better options for Baldo work and
that guard GI gets nothing but he's red
guard right now anything can happen he
might want to sole charge just to be
okay I guess we're gonna find out here
he's got me to work with but you know
you talk to his historically not really
used as leader a lot that's God that's
guaranteed goodbye
nice one you can't step there because
there's just too much it's a guarantee
car brake much bus till out my stuff to
work yeah I mean I guess he could
alright actually he could dad might work
or he could like mash so charge well I
mean it might be a force block situation
so you know in first boxes rowdy and
actually people part but yeah as I was
saying you Toto has historically and
pretty much every event we've seen him
so far barely use his bar whether it be
so charge to you pretty much only uses
it for CD from I feel like I've seen
something like this a long time ago and
it was some Enders Jaso monsters from
the you know and you know I find out
what players who consider their so
charged week right so like Votto guy a
Cervantes guys sometimes don't think
there's so charges very goods like that
I find out one when players dignity are
so charges week that they just don't
utilize it because it's like to them
it's like they uses mechanic okay
they're not just into the concept look
like did not get to your guys so then I
use like hey this is the birds you can
use it to get away from people right
yeah dad that cause of dissolutes the
ditch not into it for whatever reason I
guess so I don't know possible mix of no
tights though as lugar just blocks at
all whoa well that's away from it that
was really good awareness from Utah you
recognize the situation and tried to
stop unfortunate this wall you toto
he needs a big launch so if there's
something card bar look at blue gone
this is the first round
how do you do so much card down in the
muscle posture
I mean you know he's got enough life
that a guard break would not really faze
him too much right so he was not worried
about having to be too defensive or
anything
[Music]
and especially now that he's head he
probably won't see it guard Brogan as
soon as possible honestly go [ __ ] on to
break that that's a great stuff he did
not wait punish you total of
characteristic
well that's time it was all faxes ran
you tried to a Punisher it was just
superb up yeah so try to keep the
pressure going whoa believeth guaranteed
over clashes like that's grace as well
police back turn AAA
the bat turn man this is just not enough
blue god six PA has been mixing up left
and right I mean a lot of the muscle
Buster had been coming out prior to that
so I guess it was trying to Crouch block
and then he just gets hit oh wow caught
him wouldn't was coming out I thought
that was gonna TechCrunch it and get him
out but yeah to a you recognize that
here was negative story trying to press
a button but you try if you Toto once
again knew then he knew that I knew nice
pigs he needs that was the same
situation as last time where God tried
to step right and he won for it but that
time I thought I was ready he needs to
the thing is like you told us pressure
here is still nice carry that car flies
spin bread basic uses to beginning of
the match but he hasn't found a way to
use his brake attacks or anything to
really open it up the thing is when
you're trying to break card a lot of the
time here you're kind of predictably
using a lot of verticals because they do
more cart damage on average and blue God
is looking for that my kitchens okay
turn K man GI I just guaranteed damage
which also put some attacks so so that
that guaranteed damage puts him in acts
stance and I think you total recognize
that oh it's gonna put your nightstand
so muscle buster is probably gonna be
your option here okay
early so charcoal blue cod I'd like to
point out that you total still has not
used any bar
again tonight evil soul attack votos is
not bad historically he just doesn't use
it that often where we go this is the
first soul charge we're seeing of the
set again so cha-cha new guy just trying
to keep momentum yeah he's got to put
that pressure on ran cuz look at him at
court David you caught look at the head
that's a new attack again
muscle buns gonna catch him while oh my
god it went over the to way incredible
baby blade actually win over the 2a
[Music]
oh my god 2:04 blue god and you know
what do total I almost feel like we're
not seeing you know like the optimal you
total he's getting close he's
establishing these small big subs but
he's not he's not getting like that huge
pressure he's not getting those crazy
crabs that we saw from earlier and it's
almost like blue God's not afraid yeah
well I mean he's not afraid because he's
figured out how to make it so that it's
impossible for him to do it he's gonna
get the Walker this is so I can
completely understand that right you win
the game outright if that hits so why
not go for it now you toes trying to
come back and take me back oh yeah so if
you do pay played off of the a a string
which for a lot of people who play enemy
games that you consider that an auto
combo right
it changes the frame of an era that the
frame date on it all around right so it
starts up faster it's not negative
twelve it's like negative eight or
something like that
whoa nice mix
trying to find his way out right now but
blue-blue god is fighting on the back
for pretty hot bean leaf oh that's it
that looks so weird it's one of the best
worth punished buttons like that photo
house especially considering that at 3
point condition is what book Shake led
played don't clean it there yeah just a
little bit too far away you know they
nerfed the clean hit on it again this
version full attack is gonna come out
fresh good time yeah can I take a full
combo anymore okay guaranteed damage I
wonder if he's gonna go for sole Church
do it all was weird he humped on him yep
take advantage of it Oh scary situation
I'd like the patient to buy nothing
absolute I just watch me throw a lot of
barn left on the table for you Toto he's
actually gonna burn a whole bar if you
think about it right now
Babli be playing again at the start I
might even show up oh they're supposed
to deal with that um I to be honest with
you I don't I don't know if he can
alright defo stunt you do the mix-up I
guess another jump set up oh my goodness
that was scary for the Freak attack
right there the tour comes up with nice
break sticks we got follow-up damage on
him that's so smart right there from
blue gone because he's trying to put on
a checkmate situation if he can back it
on so yeah so far blue God is knowing
grand finals of the first Soul Calibur
well to her event over the evolution
champion so again he defeated the person
who put him out of the tournament from
the last time they fought first it was
skill from the Soul Calibur world
Invitational now it was you Toto himself
he made votos offense look like a
non-issue